Nicholas are you able to tell people
what the keys are to crowdfunding or do
you feel that I know we talked earlier
and you said really you can't tell
people how to do it you just don't how
to do it yourself
yes you know it's like I think it's very
personal and they the key for our
project and I can't talk about what I
think we did right and and I know we did
a lot of things that were wrong and the
good thing about doing a three-year
campaign or 30 day or 90 day campaigns
that we can try many different things
and that's what we did you know many of
them were period failures and many of
them were successes what I think is I
mean the reason I think like you know
it's very difficult to advise on how to
make a crowdfunding campaign is because
I don't think people in something else
related to film or art you know if your
grant funding I don't know something
physical that you're selling it's like
you're selling a product but if you're
talking about something in authority
I think people give you money not
because the project but because of you
something very personal you know it's
like I always say we've we've done two
films one of them is the customer which
is you know a science fiction film
whatever and the other thing is the
story of three guys you know three
students willing to make a film and how
we told that story over three years with
videos on the blog and you know
everything we spoke about this world
made people engage with us and willing
to give us money and if the project have
been about anything else it would have
been the same that's my guess I'm not
sure I might be wrong maybe everyone
loves to space on the space race but you
know it's kind of I think it was about
especially the film but the way we talk
about it so I guess it's it's you know
the success of rally will depend on on
the person behind and how good he is
able to express himself and to eat
anyway pitch the pride
so people are investing in you not sort
of I guess somebody you know some of
them is investing in the film itself and
actually there is people that doesn't
even know who is behind you know it
happen to have it like okay the coroner
I know the cosmonaut project and who you
are okay I'm the director hello but you
know I think that comes after it's like
the first people that is going to start
talking about you it's gonna do it
because they like what you're telling
them or the way you are telling them I
don't know I might be wrong it is I
think it's really difficult and it's
been like now everyone's doing
crowdfunding all the time with with
thousand projects and you know many of
them are things like success which is
sad but I think we are in the beginning
of something you know it's like
something is gonna grow and needs to
adapt you know I think we are living a
pretty pretty exciting time and that we
have given a huge opportunity as
filmmakers to not only because we have a
lot of things that we didn't have like
15 years ago
that allows us to make films which is
much cheaper and easier and all that but
because we are in a really image change
of model and a change of how the
industry works you know at that point
where were everything changes which is
what happened you know when the sound
came to film or when the new Hollywood
renewal bag arrived that they were you
know changing everything how it worked
and we're at that point now we are we
are one of those point up where we are
going to define the next 20 or 30 years
of film I think is pretty exciting to be
there so related to crop family know
Creative Commons or new distribution
models or transmedia I think you know we
need to be mistaken we need to just try
things and for them to go wrong we need
to have a thousand failures in funding
to get one success and see and say okay
that was the way to go
or you know yeah it's like when once
when you have a success in anything you
know you have the film about magicians
and then you have ten films about
magicians so because you know it's a bus
and probably the only success is gonna
be the first one because it was the
first one and that's but so we need to
you know keep doing things and keep
building and discover what's coming next
you